und hier sehen Sie einen Vollidioten der
sein Frühstück reinholen wollte und
einfach nicht hin zu Textstelle
irgendwie dumm aber ich war einfach nur
im Bademantel und nackt da drunter nein
Leute angekommen Köln ich war so lange
nicht mehr hier ne will endlich mal
wieder in Köln und ich dachte mir oh
mein Gott ich wollte das nur machen in
dieses fucking Hotel was sie direkt am
Dom ist ich habe das einfach mal gebucht
dass das teuerste Hotel in Köln hin
haben wir es ja doof zack zack und dann
schlafe ich heute nacht den Kinder
aufessen und sowas wirklich echt nice
Sebastian haben gleich noch also escape
und ich glaube ich werde mich da ganz
wohlfühlen also gehen wir direkt bereit
ist ja hier um die Ecke ne weißt ja
nicht weil die Story dahinter ist als
ich so 10 war oder so war ich mal in
Köln mit meinen Eltern und dann war da
madonna und ich dachte so Alter wie
krass was ein krasses Hotel und jetzt
habe ich das einmal gebucht heißt es
geht übrigens um das Excelsior Hotel
Ernst wie gesagt ist direkt am Dom die
haben ja nicht nur ein Fünfsternehotel
sondern ein 5 Sterne Superior Hotel also
platt gesagt noch ein bisschen besser
als 5 Sterne hat das Hotel ist seit 1863
familiengeführt und die Zimmer fangen so
preislich Norma also bei 300 € an für
die excelsius Suite kann man aber auch
gerne mal über 3000 € bezahlen das war
mir dann doch zu teuer
Lieferando
[Musik]
achso ja dann nehme ich doch den hier
Schau mein lieber Scholli das war jetzt
aber ganz schön viel Information auf
einmal wird sich lohnen was noch 40 €
obendrauf egal hier sind 132 dann gehen
wir da jetzt mal hin ich fühle mich wie
im Schloss versteckt man gar nicht dass
sie direkt am Dom Hotel ist ne 32 ja
klasse, jetzt habe ich einen Schlüssel
[Musik]
es werden die
man im Zug angereist ich immer
Kopfschmerzen Handy macht die ganze Zeit
hier so rein knallt durch bin jetzt da
das hat ein bisschen gedauert du kannst
ruhig kommen die meinte gerade leider
dieses tolle Restaurant dass das
ausgebucht ist aber die haben ja noch
eine Bar mit auch na super Speisekarte
sowie dann dahingehend so leid also ohne
lang reden zeige ich mir jetzt einfach
mal wie das Zimmer aussieht Wer Kunden
dass wir zusammen und danach erkläre ich
euch auch mal wie teuer das hier ist und
ob ich das meiner Meinung nach dann
lohnt oder nicht sonst wären wir dann
morgen erstmal hier kommen wir auf jeden
Fall rein und haben dann wirklich ein
sehr sehr großes Zimmer aber gut das
kann man für das Geld auch eher
Jahrmarkt im Eingangsbereich ein paar
Schränke mit Bademantel ich glaube die
haben wir auch im Spa-Bereich kein Plan
ob der auf ist wegen Coronavirus ich
gleich mal checken Fernseher Bad Decke
hier gehen Warum ins Badezimmer ist auch
sehr majestätisch achso ja hier haben
wir dann auf die Toilette und das war's
dann auch ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich
gerade gehört die Dame meinte ich habe
einen Classic Einzelzimmer gebucht ihr
müsst da auch neue moderne Zimmer und
jetzt habe ich halt noch mal 40 € mehr
bezahlt mega unnötig eigentlich aber gut
wenn ich jetzt schon mal hier Filme dann
könnte ich mir das auch Bastian zahlt
ihr das Essen von daher mal das wieder
raus dann weiter nur halt noch nicht ja
genau und das hier ist jetzt alles ein
bisschen moderner ne weil ich glaube
sonst ist dieses Hotel auf jeden Fall
eher so altmodisch zumindest die Bilder
die ich im Internet gesehen habe was da
hier links und rechts neben dem Bett ist
natürlich mit im Preis drin und hier
hinten habe ich jetzt gerade schon
gesehen haben war die wunderschöne
Minibar die auch wohl mit im Preis drin
ist das habe ich doch richtig verstanden
oder und da muss ich sagen das ist das
allererste Mal dass ich irgendwo telwin
und die Minibar ist einfach mit im Preis
drin castoreum war ein bisschen
Apfelsaft Orangensaft und viel Kaffee
Köln
da kann ich mir erstmal eins habe ich
das lange nicht mehr getrunken ne mit
klar wunderbar ja ja das wird heute
alles so weggespült hier erstmal Schuhe
aus und
ja
gut kann man was mit anfangen was auch
immer Leute genießt ist erst ab 16 Bier
auf meine schöne Köln Zeit ich habe hier
drei Jahre gewohnt und war jetzt zwei
Monate nicht hier da kann man sich das
auch mal gönnen oder
wir müssen noch bisschen weiter
erforschen hier oben ich glaube hier ist
Kaffee drin oder, ja so kann man sich
morgen hier schönen leckeren Espresso
oder auf einen Cappuccino machen und
Leute was ich auch super interessant
finde mir hat man neben dem Kopfkissen
wenn man die halt wahrscheinlich länger
schläft kann man auswählen zwischen
Dinkelkissen Nackenkissen
Kirschkernkissen Synthetik Kissen
rosshaarkissen Nackenrollen also ich
wusste gar nicht dass es so viele
verschiedene Kissen gibt für mich sind
Kissen halt einfach Kissen home Service
hier steht irgendwas mit iPad
von dem Tablet gesprochen und das haben
wir auch da kann ich bestellen wir doch
direkt mal obwohl nee sebastian ist
gleich da in dem erstmals essen und dann
bestelle später Frühstück also Leute bis
gleich ach so bevor ich es vergesse so
sieht übrigens draußen aus wir haben
hier kostenlose Corona Test und Istanbul
Restaurante und so hier Mini Balkon zum
Rauchen nicht dass ich bisschen
gefährlich sebastian und ich haben uns
dann in der wirklich super super
wundervollen Bader und ich extrem wohl
gefüllten leckeren Burger gegönnt für
sage und schreibe 26 € den Burger dazu
dann noch ein paar Bierchen um genau zu
sein 12 und insgesamt haben wir 113 €
bezahlt kann man mal machen sollte man
nicht zu oft machen Leute was geht mir
mittlerweile 0:30 Uhr ur was ich bin
gerade erst aus dem ostrong von unten
wieder hoch gekommen dass man Sebastian
noch einige Zeit in der Bar echt mega
nice also jemand super wohlgefühlt haben
wir ein paar Kölsch gezischt und jetzt
wollte ich mal gucken was man hier noch
so machen kann und was ich euch auch
nicht vorenthalten wollte hier haben wir
so einen Schalter und du kannst dir
alles über Steine du kannst alles
ausmachen und dann kannst du auch alles
anmachen und jetzt kann mir mal hier zu
diesem Tablet muss jetzt unbedingt mal
ausprobieren das einzige was mich ein
bisschen ab sagt genau vor mir ist einer
Straße und da fahren die ganze
Polizeiautos lang weil wir sind halt
direkt am Dom Problemvierteln Köln ich
lag auf jeden Fall gerade auch schon
eine Zeit lang hier im Bett und es ist
super bequem also das Bett ist eine 10
von 10 bis jetzt das Tablet vom Hotel
was man so mitnehmen kann die kann ich
ja jetzt eigentlich auch noch um diese
Uhrzeiten Snack bestellen Sie mir noch
gesagt ne wie geht's halt wirklich eine
Fackel Nacht Karte von 12 Uhr bis 6 Uhr
ohne Scheiß sieht geil ist dass ich war
so oft irgendwo und hat die Nacht so
hunger und es ging gar nichts letzten 2
in Rotterdam da macht alles zu um 22 Uhr
du kriegst nirgendwo mehr was zu essen
irgendwo wirklich also es gibt hier
wirklich warme Gerichte mit Chili con
Carne Kartoffeleintopf und die meinten
ja auch ich kann hierüber Frühstück
bestellen ojama das Frühstück Rührei und
so weiter da steht kein Preis dran
eichengrund oder oder vielleicht ist
Frühstück aus und Pauschalpreis ich
meine Frühstück kostet hier 40 € ja aber
es ist schon sehr hart ich meine es
kostet 40 € oder 38 € oder so deswegen
bestelle ich jetzt einfach mal für
morgen früh und Pancake mit Puderzucker
oder Ahornsirup und hier steht jetzt
gerade achso warte malvor noch nie
Getränke habe ich ja hier Getränke habe
ich alles zu bei wie möglich die das
vermisst heute zum 4 Uhr und 20 Uhr
verfügbar also ich kann theoretisch
Vampiro Frühstück bestellen aber wir
müssen das ist auch geil das Zimmer hier
muss ich erst um 13 Uhr verlassen
normalerweise elf oder zwölf Uhr gang
und gäbe aber hier nicht 13 Uhr deswegen
ganz entspannt Frühstück 10:30 Uhr danke
so absenden Frühstück bestellt auch
nicht immer so müde was geht guten
Morgen Ich habe ein paar bis 10 Uhr
gepennt ja warum nicht die Nacht war
ganz gut nur im Bad weil manchmal so ein
komisches Geräusch können aber was ist
wahr und das bessere ist Frühstück
kommen jetzt gleich ganz alleine auf
mein Zimmer gefahren aber ich gehe jetzt
erstmal duschen
und hier sehen Sie einen Vollidioten der
sein Frühstück rein holen wollte und
einfach nicht hin zu Deckstelle
irgendwie dumm aber ich war einfach nur
im Bademantel und nackt da drunter nein
danke schön Ciao Digger ich bin so dumm
ich wollte eigentlich dass ich habe das
nicht gesagt ich habe Früchteteller
gesagt oder ich wollte eigentlich diesen
Joghurt mit Früchten also ein
Joghurtbecher nein jetzt habe ich ihn
Früchteteller sieht auch gut aus was
haben wir denn jetzt die Hälfte davon
kenne ich gar nicht was ist denn das
hier
[Musik]
sollte
für mich heißt das Zimmer habe ich denke
ich ganz gut hinterlassen ob sich das
gelohnt hat oder auch nicht das erkläre
ich euch gleich drei
Leute was geht ab ich bin mittlerweile
wieder zu Hause und dachte mir ich mach
noch mal ein kleines Fazit ich sehe
bisschen fertig aus ich hatte heute echt
einen stressigen Tag aber trotzdem
versuche ich das jetzt bestmöglichen zu
bekomme ich habe euch noch gar nicht
gesagt wie viel Geld ich letztendlich
für alles ausgegeben habe zumindest
nicht auf den Euro genau also ich habe
das Zimmer gebucht das hat mich 208 neu
kostet für eine Nacht das war jetzt
Einzelzimmer hinzu kam dann noch mal 40
€ die ich und ob bezahlt habe und hatte
ich ein moderneres größeres Zimmer dass
ich das jetzt gelohnt hat oder nicht
weiß ich nicht weil das andere Zimmer
habe ich nicht gesehen aber wir gehen
einfach mal davon aus dann kam noch 15 €
Kurtaxe für köln dazu was sie genau fürs
Frühstück berechnet haben weiß ich nicht
es wird mit meiner VISA Card und nichts
abgebucht und die Rechnung die ich
mitbekommen habe da ist halt nur diese
40 € plus Kurtaxe drauf bisschen los
werde ich noch erfahren ich gehe aber
von 38 € auf und abends vor mir noch
essen das habe ich durch zwei geteilt
also wir laden schon sobald für dann 50
€ für eine Nacht mit essen und
Verpflegung natürlich alles andere als
günstig aber ich muss sagen wenn ich
jetzt mal wirklich das Detail betrachte
auch wenn ich das nie nie nie nie
niemals privat ausgeben würde für ein
Hotel man merkt schon warum man so viel
Geld bezahlt also das Service die rufst
da an zwei Minuten später kommt jemand
bringt dir was überall stehen diese
Service Menschen in blauen Klamotten die
einem jeden Wunsch von den Lippen
ablesen alle sind super nett und
zuvorkommend das Zimmer ich habe noch
nie so was sauberes gesehen da du
konntest nichts finden da war alles
sauber also wirklich alles im Traum die
einzigen negativen ich habe mein Zimmer
war direkt an der Straße da hast du halt
leider Krankenwagen und soweit alles
gehört ist halt ne laute Ecke da das war
ein bisschen nervig nachts und der
Burger im Restaurant oder in der Bar
waren nicht so ne also auf jeden Fall
keinen Burger der mich jetzt überzeugt
hat und ich habe schon viele gegessen
sonst wirklich alles super wenn wir den
Preis mal außen vor lassen 9,5 19 Punkte
will ich geben mit Preis h singt das
dann natürlich aber wenn man auch so
geile luxuriöse Hotels steht das
Extension Köln check das super gerne ab
geiles Hotel muss ich sagen dass das vom
Video nächste Woche wahrscheinlich in
Berlin da habe ich so einen kapselhotel
im Blick was ich mal checken wollte ihr
könnt euch darauf freuen Leute und haut
rein danke fürs zuschauen ciao